皆さん汗かきますかこの部屋に引っ越したんですけどもうなんか空調空気清浄機みたい
なあるもののめっちゃ熱いんですよ超熱いこれにエアコボないしうわぁ凄いか国の中で
動画を撮っております弾み雪をですもう今はついんだけども
結局人っていうのは汗をかきたくないと思うんですよ僕もそうだし君もそうでしょ人
っての汗をかきたくない生き物
んですよなぜかというとなんかこう臭いとか汚いとか汗のあれかつくと嫌じゃないです
か
そりゃやですよねきっと男も女も嫌だと思うんですけどもう結局字や人なんで書くのは
仕方ないんですけどもやっぱばれるのが嫌なんで
結局粘れなかったらいいと思うんです汗をかいても誰かに子が汗かいてるって思われる
のが者なんでちょっと今回ですね検証で売れたキャスを変えたら1
にバレるのかという検証ちょっとしていこうと思いますまぁ僕も人間なんで汗の量を
コントロールできないんでまぁちょっと何度か捨て汗を正そうと思いますたぶんこれで
大体何リットルぐらいの汗をかいていくかが多分
目安として分かりやすいと思うので他に検証で皆さんが書いていい当ての量が決まり
ますので参考にこれからそれ書いてください
[音楽]
うん
は大
p
なんかシフト b をしちゃったなんか出てきた1
これこれはこのままて速度があるか
うん速度が出てるだけああもうこげぱんちゃんカスタムで
何パーセント400って言ったら4倍そびの3日ありがとう
やっぱり
鯖江ただねぇねぇ
ni
me
uh
teame
car
me あった